this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you know
the cash shop it's the simplest way to
instantly send money to friends it's
also the number one app in finance but
it didn't get there on payments alone if
you thought that your silly these days
cash app is changing how people interact
with their money it's adding features
you can only get from a bank and more
than a few that you can't like the new
cash card boosts and bitcoin download
the cash app for free on the App Store
or Google Play market this is how we do
it we're doing a tee up as we did 80
episodes god damn I must have said some
incriminating [ __ ] in these past 80
episodes and it's hot as [ __ ] my babies
and we're going live on my app here
they're all tuned in listening to my
watchin watching me to speak on the
microphone before anyone else it does ok
so what's up my babies hi Lacey
Chrissy rose chat live in four we see
you we see y'all Pierluigi for annatto
mama that's [ __ ] I didn't know I had
many Italian babies but it's 91 degrees
in Los Angeles and Stu ha now here's the
deal
are there boa constrictors outside no
they're for the degrees should be less
but yeah I am in Los Angeles I've been
in Los Angeles for a bit I've been
chilling my doggies not not like DMX
like a real person Channel
my doggies and I love my doggies and I
love all doggies and I see all doggies
and I go like this oh and if you don't
you [ __ ] psychopath I thought about
this if you don't like dogs if you don't
like babies you're [ __ ] psychopath um
speaking of Psychopaths my buddy told me
that he had sex with a girl and he did
it and they had sex for an hour and I
want to talk about this because that is
[ __ ] way too long this is how long
you have sex for at the most 25 minutes
that's it you go a minute over 25
minutes you're it's not good anymore you
know she gets dry you your your boner
loosens up a little bit you know and and
and it's just too long dude it's too
long and that's [ __ ] obvious and if
you are a chick and you're like no I
like to get [ __ ] out no you don't know
you don't dude I love when dudes are
like I could I'll [ __ ] you all night my
dude one of my favorite things to think
of is it dude that's just like hey man
or like to the chick he's just like I'm
gonna [ __ ] are you ready I'm gonna [ __ ]
you all night oh yeah and they're naked
and he's about to go inside her and he's
just like I can't wait to just [ __ ] you
all night and then he slides inside of
Music's oh god and then it's over that's
my favorite thing to think about sex
wise just like immediately like you get
ready for a night of pleasure oh yeah oh
you're looking good I am gonna take my
time
[Music]
that's just so funny to me dude
you know it's happened so many times
these [ __ ] Marquez [ __ ] dude
an hour
some people have sex for it over that
dude I've never done that if you're
coming to me for a long sex like that
you're gonna be disappointed man I
Berber upfront I open with my closer
dude that's how we do it
I [ __ ] top-load sex that's how we do
it man
we study Berber within 25 minutes dude
if you're [ __ ] pretty long you know
prolong in the Berber you're in your
youth if you're prologue in the Berber
dude and this is how this episode is
gonna be man we came up with the title
already prolong in the Berber this is
how it's gonna be if you're one of those
people that tune in and think oh I can't
wait to think of what the [ __ ]
episode titles gonna be tuned out now we
got it it's prolonging the Berber but if
your [ __ ] if you're prolonging the
Berber because you think the girl likes
to prolong the Berber or you're like oh
yeah I'm gonna do it for my ego cuz I
could [ __ ] prolong my Berber forever
dude you're nothing you're a beta dude
you're not in charge I'll tell you that
much you're not in charge you're not in
charge you're not in charge of a [ __ ]
tribe there's no way you're in charge of
a tribe if you [ __ ] for 25 minutes or
less you can be in charge of a tribe
that's it because you've got nothing to
prove
and I'm talking 15 minutes is probably
the golden hour the golden amount of
time - I think it's honestly 12 minutes
I think the golden amount of time - to
do the horizontal mambo is 11 12 minutes
and then you Berber right between that
11 12 minute mark dude if you're going
longer than that what are you doing also
what's up with these guys that say they
can do it like three four times in a
night you know how many times I can do
it in a night one then I go to bed the
next morning I wake up and I don't think
about sex for another day one you get
one
you get one Berber you get 12 minutes
every two days that's what you get and
if you're in a relationship you're lucky
to get [ __ ] two Berbers a week
the only time you're having sex for an
hour is if you're in a relationship and
you're trying so hard to be attracted to
each other because you can't Berber I
[ __ ] front love my Berbers man that's
it man I don't I don't do you know I'm
not talking about foreplay foreplay
school do foreplay as long as you want
and one time a therapist told me
foreplay is everything you do up until
sex not including just being not
including just being in bed and I was
like oh I was like that meme of the guy
from the wire oh you know what I mean
that's what I was like four players
every foreplay is everything you do
up until sex not just in the bed I was
the [ __ ] meme from the guy from the
wire that guy what's his name
who knows doesn't matter you know what
me I'm talking about because it's
omnipresent but uh yeah that's how
that's you know it just you're not gonna
you're not proving anything you just
[ __ ] some of these guys like yeah
I've I talked about buddy though he's
like hey how many times do you have sex
like with a girl in a night and on like
one and you said give me two to it I
don't do it after that I was like yeah
and every time I've ever been with a
girl and they're like one I got again
I'm like listen I'll be [ __ ] straight
with you man we [ __ ] I top-load my
Berbers and I'm out now let's watch
infomercials or better yet I have to get
up early so what's going on here what we
doing oh man so funny oh [ __ ] I got a
meeting tomorrow
damn that's how many guys have done that
[ __ ] man I got a meeting tomorrow I
don't know really it's Sunday no it's a
church meeting I gotta go to a church
meeting oh well I got to get up early
too and you're like oh [ __ ] wait how
okay all right um [ __ ] well how early
does she probably have to get up and
then you're just like oh I gotta get up
at 4:15
oh really for a meeting no because it's
actually in Bakersfield I have a church
meeting in Bakersfield and I gotta get
there by 6:30 a.m. but I'd like to I'd
like to check my surroundings before I
get there in case of ninjas oh really
you're a [ __ ] weirdo yeah but I don't
know yeah so I don't know though that
you know but but the guy did it for an
hour dude we were roasting him in the
group chat he's the kind of guy that's
like I've you know like dude we did it
for an hour and I immediately he was
saying it like like check me out
and I was like bro hold on a second I
was like you think that's you're telling
me like I'm supposed to be impressed
that sucks when you eat a good meal you
do it for [ __ ] 12 minutes if you got
some [ __ ] pork loin and you want to
put it in your mouth you put it in your
mouth you swallow it you keep putting
bites in your mouth till you're full
you're done it's 12 minutes when you're
eating you release the Berber amount
this around the same time you don't sit
any pork loin or [ __ ] chicken pot pie
or meat loaf whatever the [ __ ] you like
you don't eat ice cream for an hour you
glutton it's a sin dude this guy we
laugh we were laugh-in dude an hour we
were imagining like the girl just like
oh my god get it over with like dude
like we were like somebody on my app is
just right so vagina hurts just thinking
of having sex for an hour like it's like
dude know who does you know who does
that lunatics and deviants that are just
like that they they have like a [ __ ]
it's a masochist thing there's no way
[ __ ] for an hour dude that's not cool
dude that's not cool dude we were
roasting and we were like you [ __ ]
dork
it was so funny forgot about this he was
like dude we did five six different
positions dude you know how many
positions you do when you do the
horizontal mambo three that's it you do
three positions you go on top she goes
on top and you smash it from behind you
don't do any sort of [ __ ] you know
and by the way that counts is the delay
if you're laziest [ __ ] but you still
want to hit it from behind and you're
both on the side and you're you know
what I mean that still counts as dog I
don't give a [ __ ] what people call it
you're still mostly behind them you're
just you're the [ __ ] lazy you're like
the the myth it's like the middle-age
doggy style you know it's the politician
doggy style is what that you know what
em you know I mean like you know
Republicans just laying on their side
and do it like that and they think it's
real dirty but like but like you do
three positions man ii anybody does some
sort of like [ __ ] ii anyone does some
sort of like wheelbarrow [ __ ] or like
revert you know what you know it's not
cool reverse cowgirl get out of here
with that [ __ ] where we both looking the
same way what are we watching [ __ ]
CNN
dude I need to see your eyes cuz even
when you do doggy you can be like turn
around and look and then her hairs in
her face and you're like that's awesome
it was just like Tom Cruise in the Last
Samurai it's a gay no but like I like
how hot is it when a girl's [ __ ] hair
is in her it's weird right
haha [ __ ] yeah when you when you're
having sex with a girl and she's so lost
that she's looking like Tom Cruise in
the Last Samurai Berber dude let's get
to berber town berber town it's alright
you II just came to party Oh
[Music]
dude a Berber Terran man when you're
having sex with a girl and she's in
front of you and you're behind and
you're both facing the same way and you
say hey look back at me and she and she
[ __ ] looks back and she's got her
hair in front of her face like [ __ ]
Tom Cruise from the Last Samurai berber
City that's it that's it
berber City man this is real [ __ ] man
[ __ ] dude but he said we did five or six
different positions let's think of
positions okay I don't even know if I
can get to six you got pictures of Tom
Cruise in last summer I said going that
other right there dude you want a girl
looking like that he's a guy without the
bearded man face so so look you get on
top and by the way I don't know what
missionary [ __ ] whatever that's the
only thing I know what it's called in
doggy style I don't know what the her
being on top is called but there's those
are the three then there's you know
cowgirl or right organ reverse cowgirl
which is ass disrespectful and it's a
sexist but guess what we're talking
about sex that's okay and then there's
like I know one move which is the
wheelbarrow which I've obviously had
never done but then there's the warrior
position which is hilarious I mean look
at these positions look at what this
one's called the Capricorn he's up
against the wall his feet are up against
the wall and she's just looks like she's
taking a [ __ ] on him I don't like any
position where you gotta like bend your
dick a different a different way you
know like just have the normal way your
boners shoot up let's keep them up you
don't need them at [ __ ] half mass or
facing facing worms you know what one
sucks when like your legs in between
each other's legs they're calling the
diffusion and you like what is going on
there I like just if you want it to feel
some sort of if you want it to feel
we're on sex positions dot Club you know
but if you want to feel some sort of
different [ __ ] just get a [ __ ] ring or
something you know
those are supposed to feel good dude I
mean and I don't want it I don't want to
tell you too much about my friend
obviously but like don't brag about how
many positions you did with a girl
unless you're oh man that one one four
just brought up one called hot lunch
yeah she's so gross dude
he's just dining on her vagina it looks
like he needs a fork and knife it looks
like you'd have a [ __ ] napkin in his
you need to wear a shirt so you can tuck
a napkin into in it that's what the hot
lunch is you should just call it the
public school 0:01 fire no she's like
that's actually not I thought it's
actually just mixing laughter that's not
what it is
oh the act of [ __ ] ah God okay well
more parts actually when you step on
someone's chest I thought anyway
whatever it's gross hey don't involve
[ __ ] so German but uh yeah dude if
you're [ __ ] 11 and you have your
first sexual thing and you feel like
yeah I did [ __ ] six different
positions it's hilarious but like what
are the positions like if you're fifty
or well however old you are and you're
doing all these positions what are they
you're doing the three you're doing the
main three that people do okay what else
are you doing
like if you're 50 don't do a reverse
cowgirl
what are you doing also
counting different like the like the
warrior position is pretty normal right
I suppose I've done that but like you're
just it's not don't think of it as
another position you're just it's just
so we do people are weird when it comes
to sex man top load your Berbers and
everyone's gonna be happy that's what we
do with our comedy specials man you got
to put the heat up front because people
turn that [ __ ] off man and incorrigible
I put my hot closer at the end I think
people turn that [ __ ] off man before
they even got to it and a man on fire we
top loaded it baby you know you like to
think all it's all good but you know and
you know yeah it is but I got into a
little bit of more story tell them by
the end of it you know oh my God look at
this one called reversed reverse cowboy
you got a bend your dick so far back
it's in your own ass
Jesus um anyway yeah that was insane to
me why was I laughing we were roasting
we were roasting we were we were roast
in 1 cent y'all remember that movie that
came out we were soldiers once and young
with [ __ ] Matthew McConaughey I think
and Mel Gibson it was like yeah just
[ __ ] name it something different
these long-ass movie titles we were
soldiers young one setting young saqqaq
to name it that we were soldiers doctor
thought once and young just we were
soldiers and I know it's a book I don't
give a [ __ ]
also if you wrote a book congratulations
that's real cool if you wrote poetry
write a book stop being so lazy
alright let me tell you something and I
tweeted this the other day if if you
want to know if a poem is terrible just
ask yourself one question is it a poem
then yes it's terrible I don't give a
how symbolic it is I don't care how much
your poem is about trudging through the
[ __ ] snow and seeing broken branches
but it's really about your father dying
don't care
write a book tralala [ __ ]
hoop-dee-doo whoop did he poop poop
scoop I don't give a [ __ ]
and there are poet poets that I respect
too there are I have people that I know
that I respect that do poetry and I
would caution them to stop it's just
like what are you doing write a book put
more words on the page stanzas [ __ ] off
stanzas [ __ ] off I just don't I don't
know okay so you wrote a poem cool now
what I wrote a poem imagine imagine
imagine you're a poet and you're working
like I'm it that's hilarious
like yeah I'm working with your wife
you're just like yeah I got it I'll be
done I'll be done God I got like I got
to put six hours into my poem okay you
just don't want to hang out huh no no I
do I just [ __ ] I've been working on this
poem it's about winter and it's secretly
about my dad dying yeah you know how
that really broke me up right so anyway
I'm on the second line okay yes so
anyway I'll be give me six hours and
then I'll be ready for dinner I'll come
down okay and then at the dinner so
how's your poem going good good I'm on
the fourth line just write it quick it's
[ __ ] two stanzas write it quick
I'd uh you know and I know a lot of
people agree with me and I know a lot of
people secretly agree with me too and I
know a lot of people will tell me to go
[ __ ] myself but seriously come on dude
poetry was cool in the year 1100 then
the year 1200 and maybe to the veers
1500 and then when you got to 1,600
people are alike wait let's write books
sit down what I'm saying and then they
wrote books and then it was on and then
it was on dude we got some sweat
dripping down the Black Diamond [ __ ]
ski course on my abdomens dude I posted
a picture of me here's the deal man
all right I'm getting more fit that's no
that's no you know let's talk about the
[ __ ] elephant in the room dude
I'm getting trapped out alright let's
talk about the elephant in the room dude
I'm looking a little bit too much like
Tarzan on creatine all right let's
[ __ ] talk about it okay I post a
picture with my shirt off now am I
supposed to not post a picture with my
shirt off because I'm looking like
Tarzan on creatine or [ __ ] I would post
a picture of my shirt off when I wasn't
[ __ ] New Jack city but now because
I've got [ __ ] lumps the size of
[ __ ] moguls I gotta [ __ ] keep the
shirt on now go [ __ ] yourself and here's
the deal people are like you would roast
you five years ago you're just plain
wrong and you don't get my comedy that's
fine but you're not a baby you don't get
it dude I'm gonna do what I do I live my
life the way I live my life I'm not
gonna change it because of what the dude
I post pictures of me with my shirt off
all throughout my [ __ ] even when I was a
little bit you know I was never happy
actually tubby but like I had some fat
shirts were off don't give a [ __ ] don't
care you don't know me [ __ ]
these [ __ ] comment and trolls
think they know me they don't know me
[ __ ]
you would roasters oh this would be know
somebody said this would be most [ __ ]
up Instagram post of the week no it
wouldn't because that has to do with the
caption and that's 100% obvious and you
are not invited to the log cabin man
that's it you don't get it and it's all
good you can't get it that's why the log
cabin is for the elite few we have a
[ __ ] one-two-three-four log cabins I
don't know they're all around some tall
grass we don't have a city you're not in
you're not invited if you're a [ __ ]
dumb piece of [ __ ]
you can't come it's amazing though like
I talked about the poetry online it's
amazing what people will be upset about
now and get really upset about online
like I posted a tweet the other day
about mmm when I like everyone's talking
about Tom Cruise doing his own stunts
and [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] dude I
don't care it's not impressive to me at
all dude
it's not impressive at all that he hung
on the side of an airplane do you know
what it is it's irresponsible get down
it's also green screened out anyway
people are like ugh
if you're going to a [ __ ] movie
because somebody did their own stunts
you're a [ __ ] your cooter turn around
get out of here like what do you do
like who cares and they're like well you
can get better immersive shots and you
know dude any time a stunt is very grand
you want the wide shot anyway because
you want to get the scope of him jumping
off the bill to get a guy I don't even
give a [ __ ] get a black guy for a Tom
Cruise stunt I don't care
put him in a different outfit I don't
give a [ __ ] he's not doing that it's so
green screen anyway you think him riding
on the motorcycle and then hitting the
car and flying over the car was him do
it wasn't him doing it it was a [ __ ]
CGI [ __ ] you know why it wasn't him
doing that because of death because he
would be a dead Tom Cruise and and then
and then people are like well but yeah
those movies makes so much more money to
people come
mad at me on Twitter you were like well
those movies make so much more money
because of the excitement around the
stunt no no they don't they lose money
because he breaks his [ __ ] ankle and
they have to shut down production for
two months because he wanted to jump on
the side of a building and how about
this dude that's another guy who's not
working a stunt guy it drives me nuts
when these actors are like I got it's an
ego thing dude it's just an ego thing
it's a guy who's done too much that is
now like a little cool I want to jump
out a [ __ ] building also he's not
really jumping out of a building he's
tied the [ __ ] up and bad guys aren't
really chasing him nobody's actually
trying to shoot him
he's not on a real impossible mission so
it's not even real anyway so get a black
guy I don't give a [ __ ] get a guy who's
way taller get a gangly Croatian I don't
care how much get a guy with [ __ ]
blond hair get a blonde haired black guy
black French guy and dress him in a
[ __ ] orange spacesuit I don't care
the movies ridiculous anyway what's his
name Cahill [ __ ] cocked his biceps
for a fight hey that deserves [ __ ]
five hats that I'm not even going to do
because I'm exhausted on the head scale
it's five hats like I just
get holy hung on a helicopter like like
oh look at how the [ __ ] it was for him
trying to get that thing to know what
did he do he's hanging on the helicopter
he strapped in all right he's gotta be
strapped in what a lunatic to do this
dude if I I can't wait to do some of
these [ __ ] stunts and then be like
get that [ __ ] stunt man I don't know
man I don't know man maybe maybe I'm
[ __ ] completely wrong about the [ __ ]
you know maybe it doesn't make more
money that way
it shouldn't though that's the thing I
mean I get the gay actors face on it you
get the actors face you look at the
actors face when he's doing the stunts
he's really terrified I don't know but
that's like the thing when it's like
when when they do a movie about football
and like they're like oh you got three
football players really in the [ __ ]
in the movie and these are actually
pretty good like just get actors dude
you've got people that work so hard they
leave it their family they they they
live on ramen for [ __ ] nine years and
you're gonna and that guy tries out for
a [ __ ] part on we were soldiers once
that young and then you are like oh it's
between him and a guy who is a real
soldier but [ __ ] it I want it to be
authentic I'm gonna have a real soldier
do it
like that's so [ __ ] up dude that's so
wrong actually it just get get an actor
dude it's not that important also man
you're not you're making a movie dude
you know just [ __ ] get a guy you know
many times if some some actors have to
audition for [ __ ] like four five six
seven times dude
one time I audition like four times and
then they're like we want to see a Mick
I said no no no get someone else I don't
give a [ __ ] get someone else or pick me
it doesn't
matter I'm not all day you know if you
want me it's it's [ __ ] two scenes you
know I mean in some [ __ ] comedy or or
or even it you know just pick a guy for
commercials they got all we got to see
these no you don't know you don't
dude it's a [ __ ] commercial for or
what do you know
hefty just pick a guy off a [ __ ]
picture with a nice trim to kind of
beard and just have him take the trash
out don't call in 40 actors and see what
it looks like when they pick up a sack
just [ __ ] hire a guy [ __ ] these
companies and then not only are you
there you you're on a [ __ ] conference
call with people in a you know Sweden or
wherever that a company's based and
they're like yeah can we see him pick up
the cab AG again no no that's when you
say no dude uh all right you guys I'm
wearing them right now me undies you've
heard me talk about me undies a million
times but why am I actually so obsessed
with them well look it's as simple as
this man when I wake up in the morning
all groggy I actually get excited to go
to my underwear drawer and pick out
which be on these I want to wear for the
day you know I do it right now I got my
colorful one that my colorful ones that
are in support of pride they came out
with those on Pride Month or whatever
and they constantly come up with new
designs and it's awesome
so you know and you know and also people
either see them or they don't see them
when they're on me sometimes people
don't see them but I want to lift up my
shirt and I'm exposing my abs you know
then they see him and they think oh he's
got the colorful ones on today but
they're cool because they express the
way I want to express if I wanna and
that's why I think they're the best
underwear and they're also they use
micro modal fabric which is a full three
times softer than regular cotton I
wouldn't believe
III literally you can't believe how soft
these things aren't that crazy I was
telling my dad yesterday he was like
come on I was like dad I'll give you I
got to give you some pairs
but you want them there around your
privates you want it to be soft but it's
100% satisfaction guarantee they just
launched a brand-new membership you can
level up your top drawer with new undies
each month members gain access to
exclusive prints that no one else can
get they get special member pricing on
every product Mandy's makes and you can
switch styles or skip any month you want
to get your 15% off your first pair free
shipping and a 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me on DS dot-com slash
Congrats that's me on DS dot-com /
Congrats square cash the cash app you
know the cash shop you know cash up you
use it because you're a baby it's the
simplest way to instantly send money to
friend it's also the number one app in
finance so what you're doing if you
don't guy if young guy what you doing if
you're young guy
the cash card is a free customizable
debit card that you can use at stores or
ATMs it's linked to your cash app
balance as if it were a checking account
it even lets you direct deposit your
paycheck if you're looking for an
alternative to traditional banking
you're not alone look it's happening the
futures here and millions of Americans
have already started using the cash hard
cash cards so let's get involved
there's rewards program there's there's
never been a rewards program like boot
like boosts get instant discounts every
single time you swipe a cash got a
coffee shop Chipotle Shake Shack and
Beyond and of course when you download
the cash app and enter rewards code
Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now so that's what's up man I'm
excited to go to I'm excited to go to
Kansas City I'm excited to go to Wichita
never thought I'd be saying that and I'm
excited to go to Lincoln Nebraska what
there once had a good time and I'm gonna
get away know I've never been a Lincoln
I think I went to Omaha now that I think
about it hey I got a question what the
[ __ ] does it matter
hit um so yeah
Nebraska's Nebraska all right so I'm
going there next week or two in two
weeks and then I got Vegas and Reno and
your boys gonna [ __ ] live it up the
day after the day after Las Vegas he
performs there he's gonna [ __ ] he's
gonna stay in Las Vegas and he's gonna
[ __ ] be still living it up I'm gonna
try and join the [ __ ] thunder down
under' and just get one of those bowties
and that's it dude it would be great to
be one of those guys to be like the
least fit kinda in shape one I want to
be that guy you know there's got to be I
wonder if that is for the guy cuz when
you go to strip clubs if you're a guy
they say that I mean I've heard people
talk about this I don't know how legit
it is but like the girls who work the
most are the girls who look the most
attainable because guys can guys can
feel like they can get them you know
crazy so uh I wonder if that's how it is
for the guys like there's just like some
[ __ ] normal-looking guy like there's
[ __ ] super good look by the way those
guys I was I was listening to a guy talk
about how like if you know he was saying
like guys like or girls like when guys
are super fit and somebody was saying no
they don't think I was listening I think
it was I think sob and Rogen were
talking about this and Rogan was like no
girls like when guys are super fit and
Shah was like no they don't
and I think sobs right like they don't
want a guy who looks like they're into
themselves more than they're into the
girl they're with you know I guess some
girls like that like I did it a girl
once that was like no I liked that look
and I was like wow but then I thought if
something happened to you during
childhood like some Arnold
Schwarzenegger guy it was like touch
your butt when you were 11 but yeah
that's just like girls like guys that
look like would they would
unlike Banana Republic ad or something
like not beefy or maybe a little bit you
know but I always thought that that's
like like gay guys like that but even
like when they're super big and buff
they don't like even gay guys are like I
think they don't like that I mean it's
first something I'm obviously speaking
very generally but um I don't know man
hey those days are over you know like
we've invented iPads and Priuses like
we've got guys who cure or to cure
diseases like those guys are attractive
now back in the [ __ ] 1100 s God I've
said 11 alot on this podcast back in the
[ __ ] 900 you needed to get with the
biggest guy but also those guys didn't
look like bodybuilders they looked like
fat muscle e [ __ ] guys with fat over
their muscles because nobody was like on
no carb diets you know nobody was like
got eat protein like these [ __ ]
Joker's and every time I talk about this
[ __ ] people are like jealous much no no
I don't want to look like look like that
guy whoever that guy is that one fire
showing look at look up go down okay
here sure being Jack this is it on Quora
calm the reason a lot of body builders
started training in the first place was
because they were lacking in some social
area of their life and thought the gym
would fix the problem I'm no exception
to this sure and there's no problem with
that that's cool you go into a place
with a lot of other people you see meet
people you also look better you feel
more confident about yourself and that
is attractive and that's a good thing
we're talking about working out I don't
go back up to gain to gain the
attraction of a woman and you have to
gain the attraction of a woman you have
to stir up some kind of emotion with her
I mean who wrote this sure being jacked
may make a girl feel more protected
around you which may lead to some
hookups here and there
but being able to captivate a woman
through conversation body language and
overall swag will have farm and then in
bold more consistent results that's
definitely that's definitely true look
at this this guy who is this I'm an
evidence-based fitness guy yeah okay so
I'm going to explain this concept using
a well researched muscle building tactic
Jesus Christ Jesus Christ this gets
better better specific adaptations to
imposed demands well I don't even know
yeah it's just like to protect someone
in through the way I just don't know
look it's impressive man it's just so
weird to me when some guy just wants to
like some guys like you see like they're
like whatever it is lift it if there's
something around I'll lift it like but
there's what there but I always in my
head I there's a part of me that's
always like but there's forklifts like
you don't need to anymore create an app
work on you know I don't know it's just
not useful anymore and these guys even
at the top of their like how many
bodybuilders make a lot of money for I
mean you got guys especially now like
you got that one guy [ __ ] forget his
name who has the the green Lamborghini I
think I talked about him on the podcast
that guy makes money but yeah I don't
know I was talking to Kalin I got a
buddy who is big and strong and fit and
good-looking and he came to the comedy
store once in kaolinite pounds always
Brian Collins always impressed by
[ __ ] people's size and fitness and
it's so annoying and you know that if
you're a fan of him at all I mean it's
all stand up is it literally about his
body so
he was like hey what's up with that guy
he's big I was like yeah he's like what
does he do and I was like he just works
out and he was like nothing huh like
yeah just works out he's like man
imagine that imagine being that big and
just working out and just not doing
anything with it that sucks huh and I
was like yeah you're kind of right huh
it's crazy but if you're big you're big
I mean what the [ __ ] you know you're
born that way so but these guys that
just want more and more mass swear this
[ __ ] didn't know is here I've been
feeling good lately man for real these
hikes are [ __ ] awesome and get out
there and hike dude it makes you feel
good and it doesn't make you feel good
when you're doing it trust me
and even though like sometimes we do six
mile hikes and it's just two hours or so
and maybe not that long but the rest of
the day you're just [ __ ] you know but
the next day and the next day you're
just like I'm walking on sunshine oh
dude it's hard man it's hard it's
[ __ ] harder than anybody who tells
you it's not hard it's [ __ ] you know
they'll be like oh you did an easy one
why don't you try to not shut up dude I
got my buddy I go with sometimes he did
like what did he do um Kilimanjaro
like he said he went with his ex and it
was a six-hour way no it was like a 16 I
don't know it was [ __ ] high all right
it was a lot and they start at midnight
because it's you know cold and then by
the time they get to the table yet six
hours later but I'm gonna get to the top
they watch this this sunrise he said he
went with his ex and he got up to the to
the top of the mountain and as the Sun
was coming up they both looked at each
other and started crying and as much as
I want to be like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's so dope actually that's so real
that's one of those things that you
laugh at but then you do and you'd be
like wow life is [ __ ] amazing
you know but that doesn't exclude you
from getting roasted if you tell people
that in the in the group chat you gotta
take your [ __ ] lickin's man I don't I
don't I don't I - I saw a guy on the
hike by though is so uh Oh was I say the
minimum number of days is 5:00 to get to
the top of him - Kilimanjaro Wow
so it wasn't Kilimanjaro obviously Jesus
Christ it was some other hike anyway
anyway um I saw this guy with four dogs
at least there might have been five I
don't even know there were so many I was
like I didn't count cuz I was so tired
walking up the [ __ ] but yeah he was like
come on come on guys come on and the
dogs were going and he was like come on
and they would immediately they'll go
like 20 feet and then find the nearest
shade and just plop down it was so
[ __ ] cute and I was like come on guys
I'll try to get him out but they were
just panting and then one dog wouldn't
go anymore and he just picked it up and
started walking with it but did the
[ __ ] the dog a big dog I'll post it
on my Instagram story go to it but it
was funny man and but these dogs were
just like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I mean they like it cuz they're dogs but
also they're like dude [ __ ] this [ __ ]
for bringing us cuz you have to go if
you're a dog dude if you're a dog you're
a slave isn't that crazy
you're [ __ ] you're a slave to what
the [ __ ] your owner wants god that sucks
dude you know what I'm doing right now
being so disrespectful I'm gonna [ __ ]
order I'm gonna order some food you
[ __ ] I'm gonna disrespect the [ __ ] out
of you in order some food you guys want
some or no no
you're listening to me ordering food I'm
making money doing this podcast right
now ordering food you got to be
disrespectful to be [ __ ] respectful
men everything's a full circle you know
had his babies getting a [ __ ] grilled
salmon that's what I'm getting dude
keeping it lean dude you got it you got
to keep it lean man my buddy was like um
he's like 40 I'm 38 you know and he was
like you know I'm not gonna lose some
weight how do i how do I do it and I was
like you just [ __ ] eat better dude
and you work out that's it there's no
secret it's no secret yeah anyway I
don't know
but yeah it's uh also people I go on my
friends they want to do the hike and
they're like let's go early or late or
it's too hot at noon
dude it's hot no matter what go and
that's it
look at this [ __ ] thing right here
somebody just tweeted me what do you
think about the a.m. this may see at
Macy Winfrey what do you think about
this I imagine you're saying something
along the lines of hey just shower yeah
that's true it these shower curtains
where you can put your iPads in and
[ __ ] phones and watch stuff like just
take what you can't take a break from
watching uh flip this house you know
like take a 20 minute shower by the way
I work out sometimes on my Irish buddy
he showers uh for 20 seconds dude
there's no way he gets clean I want III
oh no I don't understand is this an
Irish thing we both enter the showers
together I'm lathering up and he turns
it off and leaves and I'm like dude he
didn't use soap or what he always seems
pretty clean though and smells fine it's
real weird man
let's look at some other questions here
we got some questions what the [ __ ] what
is that it's a thing where you can eat
your food and put your iphone on it
propped up I mean that's just stupid all
these gadgets and [ __ ] you know
everything that I go to sharper image
and that's it what do you think of
celebrities no I okay well this is a
good question Rachel Jay Stanley at
Rachel J Stanley what do you think of
celebrities who date their fans would
you ever date a fan um I don't know no I
don't I think that's probably a bad idea
you know but I don't know I mean it's it
would always it would be like you know I
mean it's different like okay take Kevin
Hart biggest comedian right I know he's
married but like if he was like if he
met a girl and she was like yeah I'm a
big fan of yours whatever but she was
like a normal check and not like hanging
out and had her own life and was like
listen I love your [ __ ] but like you
know you're not gonna get anything extra
special or whatever the [ __ ] if we date
any sort of like you know I'm not
treating you like you're above me then
yeah then you can date that kind of a
person but not like a [ __ ] screaming
fan you know oh yeah well I've probably
talked about something like this Charles
Calvin at Charles Calvet thoughts on
people who say Ibiza when they mean
Ibiza
especially when they would never say
Mexico or Berlin in refer to foreign
cities yeah no just always Americanize
it don't be that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
you want to sound don't want to sound
cultured you know there's a few words
maybe but like that's like saying
tostada
instead of tostada but somebody does a
bit on that I think it's
Brian Regan was like saying oh yeah I
was talking about a newscaster talking
about Nicaragua and she'd say it there's
a cold front in Nicaragua it's like just
yeah just say it the American Way if
you're in America wherever you are
that's where you say it okay if you go
to Spain and you're gonna talk about you
know however they say whatever the [ __ ]
I don't know a kin to give a Spain
Spanish country but you'd do it that way
when you go to Russia you do a really
talk about it and wrote the Russia way
you know try to do it the way the people
do it okay let's go you know oh here's a
good one the log cabin is asking me this
at congratz log cab hey Krista Leah how
many kids asked you kids kids oh I asked
you to party when you do colleges have
you ever gone to just get a laugh I mean
it happens every time and no I would
never go I'm [ __ ] 38 I don't even
like being in the room with them I feel
creepy doing stand-up going to party are
you kidding me no no [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way
I can't even tell you how much no
[ __ ] way I I can't even express how
much no [ __ ] way
somebody responded to that if he hasn't
he should dude that's just like a
lawsuit waiting to happen it's also not
fun I just gonna like talk to me about
there's gonna be the one guy that's like
dude man love your [ __ ] oh yeah thanks
not for real though oh thanks no no I
really okay cool thanks and there's
gonna be the one guy that's like yo bro
I don't even know who you were until
yada yada and ba ba ba ba cool man
and there's gonna be another guy that's
like hey man I just why don't you wants
to meet new people you know that's weird
maybe if you're 20 in college yes but if
you're 38 and you want to meet new
people what did you do to [ __ ] up so bad
you know God imagine being like look if
you're recently divorced you want to
meet a new girl or no guy or whatever
fine but meeting new people like friends
wise this is Caleb at a underscore Caleb
how [ __ ] is it when someone asks is
this hoop regulation-size that's not
your misunderstanding how the word [ __ ]
how we use it
it's definitely [ __ ] how it's so [ __ ] to
be like is this who preggers it's weird
that [ __ ] that grinds my gears like that
would really like if someone asked that
and they were just we were just in a
backyard
I would I would unload on him I'd be
like man you're dude what do you [ __ ]
work what do you what do you do what are
you in mergers and acquisitions and you
give a [ __ ] about this regulation-size
who gives a [ __ ] no it's it's two inches
off
can you still dunk are you a three-point
shots still gonna be as accurate
you [ __ ] pot-bellied forty
two-year-old that's so dumb you know
people do that too one time I was
playing ultimate frisbee and this guy I
was like [ __ ] around playing and just
being silly and this guy was like it's
actually much more fun if you take it
seriously and I was like I'm out done
done with all sports you ruined that you
ruined everything
it's called Ultimate Frisbee it's got
frisbee in it and the word ultimate get
out of here it's actually I'll never
crazy is it [ __ ] sticks with you that it
happens and then it sticks with you and
then you're and then you're just and
then they're just you always think of it
it's so funny that's so crazy that your
life can change like not crazy change
but it can you can be there could be
something that's all of a sudden part of
your the rest of your life in a split in
an instant
that's wild man mm-hmm
I don't never did that that's who that
guy is to me and he was from high school
and we follow each other on Instagram I
think and every now and then I see him
and I think that's that [ __ ] guy that
told me how to take Ultimate Frisbee yep
that's who you are so be careful what
you say be careful what you say it could
really affect somebody you know I could
turn him it could turn them into a
crotchety old man not that that's what I
am I'm just saying I'm giving you
examples I don't think I've ever sweat
this much man I got on my collar
clothing they hooked me up with a bunch
of [ __ ] Kol lar it's real nice it's real
cool
they hooked they have to [ __ ] daddy
up all right I guess we're pretty much
gonna be done here cuz I'm sweating my
balls off I need to get one of those
[ __ ] dice and cool air things that
don't make noises so we can have them
here Dyson that guy hey man you jerk-off
out a window for sure today at Dyson we
try to make air better we try to purify
it and we usually keep all of the
windows closed this way the air can
circulate and be very cool and also
people can tell you're masturbating
outside of it because of the glare in
the daytime and if you jerk-off out a
window when it's nighttime make sure the
lights are off Dyson pure air if that
was a commercial by the way I buy a
[ __ ] trillion of them they make
vacuums in air [ __ ] you know those
[ __ ] circular fans I don't know all
right
look square cash check out the new
booths rewards program get the cash app
and two rewards code congrats get five
dollars give five dollars - times up get
it for iOS or Android now there's new
merch follow-the-leader t-shirts and all
the other stuff from the podcast you
know you get your kuta shirts you get
the no Cudas you get the [ __ ] and all
the different shirts you get - congrats
you get the true baby you get the baby
shirt with that with this with the
pacifier and you can buy tickets to my
up to my tour follow the leader
buy tickets to my tour
the leader chris d'elia comm Wichita
Kansas City Lincoln Reno Las Vegas
Ottawa Ontario London Ontario buffalo
Buffalo Burlington Philadelphia
Washington New York Montclair Portland
Oregon Seattle and all the [ __ ] that's
uh it's no Kwame whatever subscribe to
my youtube channel
download the Chris D'Elia app for iOS
and Android and you can do that and you
can hear my hear and see my podcast
before anybody video episodes go up
Tuesdays Wednesdays and I hope you're
watching the show alone together that
I'm on which is really fun and I'm proud
of it I'm on it like four of those
episodes this season and you can stream
them all on I think Hulu and Amazon
anyway you guys thanks a lot and
remember top-load your fervor
[Music]